all righty so i'm here in nashville with
jordan peterson jordan's spending a lot
of time in nashville in fact i think
jordan may know nashville better than i
do last night you dragged me to robert's
western world and you were like you were
like the the guy of the house like they
all knew you no no luke mccrory was the
guy in the house the guitarist playing
the guitar daddy man yeah kelly's heroes
they're a deadly band yeah i will say i
feel like i was a little more dressed
for it like i was wearing a t-shirt and
a
leather jacket and you were wearing this
yeah
i didn't have my kobe boots i haven't
bought them yet i'll get a cowboy hat
combo notes from
ashfield up exactly
it was really fun being there with you
oh yeah i know that that was awesome
you're a classically trained violinist i
am yes and do you like the music oh yeah
i love that stuff i mean if you're a
good musician you're a good musician
they really know how to play
sunday special is a lot more formal i
mean i'm coming in with questions and
it's much less of kind of a discussion
between the two of us and it's much more
of kind of just me probing and jordan's
ideas but this is much more like how we
talk normally i mean jordan you called
me we talked on the phone like a month
ago and this was basically the same
conversation right this is how we talk
about different topics but yeah
different topics but i mean like this is
this is how we talk when the cameras
aren't on us people really love being in
on those conversations yeah no i i think
that the fact that people are going to
kind of get the
the
kind of the fly on the wall view of this
kind of conversation is pretty awesome
so you'll be able to see clips of my
conversation with jordan here at the
coffee shop on youtube but if you want
to see the whole conversation which
really is the way you should see it you
need to head on over to dailywire.com or
check us out on the daily wire app
you'll be able to see the whole thing
there and it's pretty fantastic
you